hey Traders it's Mike from amorphos here
and I've got some exciting news about
order flows and go charting uh we've
just released the order flows Trader
version that works with go chart and go
charting is a web based charting and
trading platform and the order flows
Trader takes go charting to the next
level by providing you with the tools
and insights you need to analyze order
flow and improve your trading so with
this plugin
you'll be able to see detailed
visualizations of the bid and ask orders
trading in the market in real time now
the order flows Trader for go charting
has all the advanced features that are
on the ninjatrader version of order post
Trader but the best part is now it is
entirely web based so there's no
software to download or install and the
oracles Trader Works seamlessly within
your go charting platform with you know
a simple click basically so whether
you're intraday scalper or swing Trader
you know orifice Trader gives you the
edge you need to take your trading to
the next level the insights it provides
are unparalleled now I'll be creating
more videos soon and doing an in-depth
walkthrough of all the features but in
the meantime be sure to head over to
gocharting.com to learn more and
activate a free trial today I think you
can be blown away by how much order
flows Trader can help improve your
trading all right so let's take a look
at it here so all what you got to do is
let me we just get the web browser here
okay so here's you know Google what you
got to do is you type in uh
gocharting.com
[Music]
okay and I think I've already logged in
here okay so I'm just gonna pull up a
chart here
I'm just going to show you how how easy
it is okay uh what I got here okay
default is I default set the Nifty but
I'm going to pull up the e-mini s p the
ES
okay and just really quick let me just
check make sure
okay I don't have it on my chart yet so
I do have a footprint so what is nice
about this new uh go charting software
with oracle's Trader is
you know you can have the simple bar
chart but if you want to expand it out
you know and get the footprint there you
go so if you want to add the actual
order closed Trader all you do right now
is you go into the Oracle tools and
you'll see here it's called order flows
Trader just click on it okay now it's
going to I can see it here in my layers
that it appears right here and I can
take a look at the settings by opening
it up and I can see here right my
exhaustion prints and balance reversals
the ratios you know the numbers above or
below the bars the slingshot pointer
control Market weakness sequencing
sweeps uh Prominent Point of controls
inverse imbalance zero prints thin
prints tails
Etc and they've actually what they've
done is you know in order to put my
software on their platform they've
actually improved their own
um
you know their own software in the sense
of you know imbalances to bring it in
line uh with what I normally look at so
you know they call their footprint the
cluster chart so
it's very it's a very robust system
right so if you're using ninjatrader
you're going to be sort of Blown Away
it's going to be a slightly different
um
you know sort of user experience because
obviously it's a completely different
platform it's going to take you some
time to get used to but
um you know they have certain things on
here they've added into you know sort of
their defaults in the sense of you know
having things like the value areas now
as a default putting the imbalance is on
you know just within printing of the
footprint they have uh just really quick
you hear you know you could show even
imbalance
color if you wanted to change it
right you can even highlight the actual
imbalances in there but again it's very
flexible it's it's an it's a very robust
system it's not something you're going
to learn in in five minutes it's
something that you know I've created a
series of videos that you can watch on
all the functions that I use with order
flows Trader you know every every sort
of indicator that we have programmed in
here I have I have information on but I
just want to take you sort of through
some of the steps here so
you know for example thin print right
thin prints is something that I like to
use in my trading
um you know so
you see let me just uh where am I here
this is e-minis this is
two in the afternoon let me just go back
to around the cash cash open at 8 30
here okay obviously it's gonna be the
busiest time of the day when the cash
opens until the cash flows but let's
just uh scroll back and there's a couple
ways you could do it right you know you
could scrunch up your chart and then
just sort of drag it over
that's sort of you can actually just
really quick you can adjust you know if
you just want to look at the regular
trading hours or the 24 hour session
it's as simple as clicking this little
button down here
back and forth okay so I have it uh
right now set for regular trading hours
okay just
for the purposes of this video in case
you're wondering what this Gap was here
okay so I'm gonna expand it up a bit
here so
thin prints okay just really quick again
I've got a whole series of videos which
I'll show you how to access that for
free explaining the the settings so what
you gotta do is you gotta go to layers
go to setting here thin print and I'm
just going to set it to you know a level
of say five contracts okay and what it's
going to do is going to highlight on the
order flow chart where
the
in the footprint inside the footprint
you have these areas of thin volume
right you can see here uh three
two three four okay
um even back here right one
right you can see that's important
information if you're a Trader you know
a lot of people get caught up you know
with order flow in the sense of trying
to read
where heavy order flow is coming in
where there's a lot of volume coming in
but it's just as important to understand
those areas where there's lack of volume
coming in in the two-way auction you
know it's a little hard to see on this
chart maybe I could blow it up for you a
little bit but you can see generally at
each price level there's you know 100 at
least 100 contracts and you got one
contract in the two-way auction here
what does that tell you this tells you
that there's some momentum in the market
the market is moving
um pretty fast but again that's just one
of the tools that you know you can use
we've even got the
uh you know things like the Prominent
Point of controls
you know turn off the look back there to
highlight the areas where there's the
Prominent Point of controls let's see if
there's
any in here
nothing yet you know here's a bearish
Prominent Point of control here
you know here's a bullish one it was a
bearish one then another bullish one
bullish one
um and so on so you know all the tools
that we have in the ninjatrader version
of order flows Trader is available on go
charting now and as you get more used to
go charting you're going to learn that
there's some actually they have some
neat features in there that you know
just on from a trading standpoint I
don't want to get into it right now on
this video but you know if you wanted to
you know like this is your normal bid
ask footprint chart right you could
actually
determine what you want to put on
you know instead of the volume say you
just want to see okay it's really quick
here so let me just expand this chart up
I'm getting you know I'm so excited I
don't know where to start with this I'm
like a kid in the candy store
[Music]
um
you can so here so I've got
you know on the left of the bar is the
cell I'm sorry the the left this is the
left this is the cell volume this is the
buy volume on the right hand side you
know say I want to look at what the
Delta is right I could change this side
to the Delta and then the right side you
know I'm not going to look at the buy
volume maybe I'll look at you know maybe
just the total volume
Okay so
you know you could really play around
with you know what you want to look at
right here's the Delta trades you know
you got the volume well I had the volume
up there on the other side you can even
have like the bid and the ask on one
side and you can have something else
completely on the other side
you know say you want to you could even
play around with it
um you know and show things such as you
know
the right profile or the left profile
again depends on what you're putting up
there on your chart I'm a big believer
of just putting don't put every single
thing that's available on your chart put
stuff on your chart that is going to
help you okay you don't think oh I got
all these tools I got to add everything
all at once no it's not about that right
it's just simply about
putting on
you know what you want to look at that's
going to help you make trading decisions
okay
so
right now okay right now what is this
I'm recording this video on August 8th
you can actually access the order flows
Trader
add-on for free for the rest of this
month but the one thing is you will need
a goal charting account which is free to
set up but you're also going to need
data and normally the the data feed the
real-time data feed for CME is
um it's like 35 bucks for them for the
month but I've worked out a deal with
go charting to get you that data feed at
a at a reduced price okay because you
know you can't run the software
without real-time data I mean you know
if you're
going to be using
um you know the footprint you know you
want to be watching it in real time
right you want to get take the most
advantage of your
um you know your free use of the
software
when
you could use it the most so what you
have to do the link is in the
description below but it's just gonna
you gotta pay ten dollars for the first
month okay if you're going to keep it
it's going to renew at the regular price
of 35. and again you know
in my opinion I think if you sign up you
can get the delayed feed but you know
for 10 bucks a month
for you know the first month it's worth
it right I I think so and you know
what's great about it is you know I
don't know what kind of phone everyone
has I've got the Samsung bold phone you
know which sort of folds out like a book
and I watch the footprint chart there
you know if I'm if I'm out if I'm out at
dinner and I don't want to be listening
to my kids I just open up my phone and
start looking at the market right
[Music]
um
yeah it's just a it's a great tool but
let me just to sort of take you through
the the sign up process so
um let me get a let me get a web browser
back here really quick
okay well
I'll just make it easy I'll just open up
a new browser and you know let's go sort
of incognito mode to sort of take you
through the setup here so let me just
expand that so again go to uh
gocharting.com
and you know what you're going to need
to do is
yeah you're going to need to set up a an
account okay well actually
let me uh let me just I'll I'll tell you
what I'll just go through here because I
already just went through the sort of
the steps for somebody else what do I do
are you going to go charting okay you're
going to click on upgrade okay it's
gonna take you to this page you can see
there's India markets there's crypto
markets
4X right you can see what you can get
here right if
again if you're 4X you know it's 20 or
for the
4X right it's 20 a month for the premium
but again you can get the the free but
if you want the US stuff okay is this
one here CME premium buy now right
you're gonna click that button and then
it's gonna it's gonna take you the page
here it's going to show you uh 35
dollars okay
proceed to check out
okay so you can see here there's the
discount 25 off the first month okay so
it's ten dollars right then you're gonna
just click here click you know I agree I
agree
um and hit subscribe now I do want you
to realize
um one one thing it's kind of important
okay
uh
right now with
this with go charting and the CME right
they
read down here if I buy the CME Premium
plan what do I get not get
okay so basically your if you trade
Futures on the CME you know e-minis NQ
um so these currencies 66b
um this includes obviously the micros
mes
mnq you'll get that okay it's
they provide the footprint on the most
liquid contract so if you're looking at
trading Hogs it's not going to show up
so
um if I got my
other version up here let me just get
that back here just show you really
quick uh
okay here so right this is es
um you know m-e-s
where are you here right here all right
future so
um yes it's nice it shows the the
contract there right you see how fast it
is M and Q
right and then Q you know you could
expand the charts up
make them smaller and make all these
adjustments
um you know 6E right the British sorry
the euro currency
uh number contract
okay you see how fast that is it's like
in a second
um but again you know if you're trading
Hogs he
right lean hog Futures on CME
lead contractors cover they don't
provide the cluster charts
um for that market you can get the
regular Market but uh it's it's
basically with the uh the most liquid
markets right now
um
again you know the amount of people that
trade Hogs is quite limited and
it doesn't support the options listed on
CME
um
since they do not Support options you
can't see the open interest profile
underlying Futures contracts they don't
have the new event contracts right now
they don't support the depth of Market
but if you're looking at the order flow
you don't need the depth of market right
if you're looking at the footprints
you're just all you need is
the top level data right of what
actually trades in the market
[Music]
um
they do not support crude oil
which trades on nymex but you know
just uh you know they haven't added it
yet to their contract so that would
include obviously
you know
micro micro
crude right because that trades on the
nymex right and obviously it's not going
to trade
um you know you're not going to trade
Comics either right obviously you're not
going to trade cbot that's sort of the
next line in here we don't support gold
or Metals right they support the CME
contract even though it's all under the
CME Group
CME owns those exchanges
um it's just the CME
native contracts okay so again and
they're very responsive so if
you got any questions just go to admin
at gocharting.com now just uh really
quick I'm gonna put this link also I'm
gonna work on getting these videos on
YouTube but
I've also
I'm gonna put this this link in the
description as well because it is
important
um I created a user guide on order flows
on go charting right so
um
but
59 Pages yeah so you know it explains
what each setting is for there okay
and again you know
just turn on notifications because I'll
be posting a lot more videos on oracle's
Trader on go charting okay so that you
can uh you know get alerted to you know
whenever I post a new video I'm going to
try to do it uh pretty regularly you
know I want to get it out daily
um at least one video a day hopefully
more and
again if if you
I'm gonna
also do like a a big training session
um probably next week I haven't decided
on the day yet but I'll let you guys
know
um so you can sign up for it because
um you know if I if I do a nice live
training session with you guys you can
ask your questions I think it'll help
you
um
you know allay any questions that you
have and you know on usage Etc and how
to get the most out of it because really
what I you know I don't I'm not all
these guys that just put a footprint
chart out there I want you to understand
what you're looking at and how to
um trade it so anyway guys again you
know I'm sorry if this video doesn't
make much sense I'm really just super
excited to get this out
um you know once my excitement sort of
subsides
um you know I think I'll be a little bit
more more coherent honestly so I got you
out again sorry I I'm just super excited
uh right now to get it out so
um yeah it's uh
check the link below in the description
um to get the actual
discounted price on the data and again
you know for right now it is
free I know the order flows Trader is
free go charting itself is free
um so again you you want to take
advantage of that so anyway guys have a
great uh rest of your day and and be on
the lookout for my next video bye-bye